[Music]
[Applause]
all right if you don't know if n
correction is a segment where viewers
try to find mistakes on our show so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
we don't think mistake
tonight a fan named michael done a
believes he's caught a mistake he says
it happened during an interview with
Steven Yeun one of the stars of the TV
show The Walking Dead now in the
interview I mentioned that some zombies
on The Walking Dead are now wearing Swat
uniforms and that they had learned to
protect themselves last week I think I
spotted your first ever error on the
show you were interviewing Steven Yeun
from The Walking Dead and you played a
clip from The Walking Dead and in
reference to that clip you said that the
zombies had learned to defend themselves
or protect themselves and and I love
this clip because here the the zombies
as if the walkers have figured out how
to protect themselves which is a new
which is into who wrinkles in the zombie
genre in the zombie that you're
referring to that one SWAT team uniform
they actually died in those uniforms
they didn't put them on to protect
themselves it's not like they saw the
humans coming
[Music]
well Michael while I appreciate you
delivering your zombie-related fan
correction with the lifelessness of an
actual zombie
[Music]
you're allowed to blink if you want I
think he more just was like yeah he just
he took no joy you know guess what well
he can point it out all he wants he's
still wrong you're wrong pal yeah I said
some of the Walking Dead zombies had
learned to protect themselves and I have
proof that that's the case it's all
explained in this incredible deleted
scene
deleted scene from season 1 of The
Walking Dead check it out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
[Music]
so anyway the challenge still stands if
you think you spotted an error on our
show report it at team koco.com slash
haha I found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make junk
meat out of the maestro